hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers and today
we are going to be talking about how to
choose the best
coding bootcamp for you now very quickly
though don't forget to follow me on
instagram at the black female engineer
and send me your questions that you'd
like me to answer in my q and a
video questions about me software
engineering coding boot camp
all the works anything between whatever
you want so let's get
to it so one of the very first things
you need to look at
when looking at coding boot camps is
what type of supporting
resources supporting documents or
portals
they have to aid in your learning
journey probably the easiest way to find
out is to ask
the recruiters you'll be in contact with
there's likely most time
a number you can just call ask them okay
is there a separate portal for students
where they can go through certain
homework assignments is there some type
of
online textbook or are is it just
lecture and if it's this lecture are
they recorded
do i have permission to record can i
access them later
understand what comes with all of that
learning material because if we think
about any school or any
college we had textbooks to back things
up on we had
different resources portals all of that
along with our own notes and things like
that we also had resources that we
always had access to or at least during
the course and so make sure
that those are in place for the boot
camps you're interested in the next
thing you need to do
is hop onto google hop onto yelp and
look at
the reviews for that specific location
this is so so important because there
are establishments that do not have a
very structured
um or consistent learning
environment um or program or things like
that
one location may be better than others
one everything might be good except for
one location
so look at the reviews for that specific
location
because when you see things on websites
and things like that of
testimonials and stories of people who
went through the boot camp
you don't know which program you know
they went through you don't know
which you know teachers they had and
everything so you don't know if these
you know sentiments would be shared
amongst
all the students who went through the
program or if it was really just for one
specific course in one specific program
in one specific
location so look up the reviews for your
specific
location not just the boot camp
as a whole next thing you need to ask is
what job hunt resources
are there in place for you do they just
teach you and then let you go
into the wolves and say okay pay us our
20 grand or
do they have systems in place to really
make sure that after you transition from
being a student
you are now in the hands of you know
professionals who can guide you through
your job hunt and look at
resume reviews and look at how you do
technical interviews mock interviews
all of that to make sure that you are
job hunt ready
are those systems in place or do they
just focus on
the schooling itself now this next thing
is important to look at
because i always thought it was a given
but
i guess not is do they teach algorithms
i came into boot camps just thinking i
would
you know get everything i need to know
from it and
especially when you don't know what you
don't know you don't know what's
specifically
needed and what's necessary and what
companies and jobs look for
you just trust that this institution is
going to
lead you on the right path however many
boot camps don't teach
algorithms during the boot camp now
there may be
different resources they can offer for
you to learn algorithms
like you know the textbook they provide
teaches algorithms or
if you ask an instructor a ta they would
teach you as well
see what systems are in place to teach
specifically algorithms
because even if you're not you know into
that side of things even if you're
into let's say like more front-end
design and you know
the jobs you're looking at you know
hopefully would assist you in learning
that part of things during interviews
there are many times where
you would still be asked about
algorithms asked about data structures
even if it's not pertinent for that
specific
role so it's still important to know so
that you can at least
get through the interview process and
get the job
so see what they what curriculum
they have for algorithms if any and if
not
how they subsidize that lack of you know
chapter in their course next ask them
how the parallelogram has affected
their business their business models and
their day-to-day operations
this is something that's very important
because i have
seen and heard that certain boot camps
have taken away certain offerings or
certain coursework or just changed
their structure after you know
this panda bear has extended for
now a year and so it's important to know
what you would have gotten
then versus what you're getting now that
doesn't mean it's bad you may be getting
you know
better opportunities now like maybe
prices are cheaper maybe you know they
discounted certain things or they made
certain uh programs more available and
things like that so it doesn't mean it's
bad
but it could be bad it could be bad
maybe now they don't offer
the employee guarantee maybe now they
don't offer
income share agreements those are things
that are important
to know just so you understand
is it better for me to go right now
or is it better for me to hold off until
these things come back into play
so make sure you ask them how have
things changed and then lastly
ask about their success rate not only
their success rate from you know
the average of the last 20 years they've
been in business but
the last year specifically going with my
previous point
it's important to see how this panda
bear
has affected the job hunt process for
people
the learning capabilities of people the
retention rate
it's important to know how that has
affected things
and so if they're saying you know oh we
have a 99
success rate it's like okay how about
you know the last year
and if that number drops like 60
then you know there's a problem then you
know that something is wrong if they
don't want to give you the number
or if they say something like oh well we
don't have those numbers yet it's still
too early and everything
ask some more probing questions how many
of
their graduates from the previous cohort
maybe they graduated three months ago
ask them how many of those graduates
have jobs
now that's a great way to get an idea of
success rate even if they don't have
the specific stats of the previous year
and things like that there we go
everybody make sure you ask these things
and look up these things
in order to really find the right match
for you
in terms of coding bootcamps programs or
just other intensive
learning programs so i hope this was
helpful let me know if it was and i'll
see
y'all later bye